it's alive it's
alive it's zombie
[Applause]
politicians they'll have diapers canes
and chips in their brains so you want a
bad crazy story a recent report
sponsored by the Pentagon yes our very
Pentagon suggests America's elderly
politicians could one day harness the
power of brain computer interface
devices to prolong their functional
Authority in
government meaning even as they age into
their 80s and 90s they'll just keep
going like an Energizer Bunny trapped
inside Mitch McConnell's
body and the tech could reportedly be
implanted into their brains in secret
allowing senile Senators to regain their
mobility and speech after years of
cognitive decline now it won't work on
everyone first you have to have a
brain
but it gets Wilder the report also
examines the possibility of those very
brain chips malfunctioning or even being
hacked by Foreign adversaries which
eliminates the need to bribe Hunter
Biden but the report paints a picture of
our elderly leaders alternating between
confused incoherence and artificially
enhanced clarity which got us to
wondering could this already be
happening
today we're here to answer the most
important of questions is democracy
still America's sacred
cause used to make beer brew here it is
used to make the brew beer here in
this oh Earth Rider thanks for the great
lakes I believe that America is big
enough strong enough blessed enough for
all of us to
succeed the group included
groundbreaking asian-americans like like
ver Wang and and and Joan Shang gang I'm
pronounce
shanga kaaa we just have to remember who
we are we're the United States of
America Putin's
klepto
yeah kleptocracy and cl the guys who are
the kleptocracies
so maybe it's not a far-fetched Theory I
guess our best plan is to unplug Joe
wait 2 minutes and then plug him back in
again Todd uh it's a okay is it does it
bother you that the Pentagon is spending
our money on this on basically writing
treatments for screenplays for David
Cronenberg I actually had a different
take on this I I thought that this
article and the corresponding study was
really interesting because what it also
looked at it looked at China and all the
nefarious things that China could do and
I feel like to a certain extent we were
not ready for Co and if you really delve
into that article it's basically saying
what if China or some other world power
weaponized it purposefully I mean
there's questions as to whether China
weaponized Co purposefully but what if
they did something in the future that
really they had the antidote for they're
all fine because of the social
distancing and measures that they ended
up taking when in fact they just
immunized themselves to it the rest of
the world suffered so I found that part
of it fascinating but the thing that I
don't find comforting these people that
are in DC right now especially the old
people are holding on Republicans and
Democrats you have way too many people
over 75 80 years old who should be
playing with grandkids and not running
the government and if this were to take
hold there would be CL for that there
would be powers that do that would want
them to be those vessels that they could
control like our president mhm cat it's
like they refuse to step all step aside
already as Todd says this is gives
another excuse to hang around Dian
Feinstein didn't leave until she was at
death's door it's so messed up they made
her leave just cuz she died I know you
know what would they do that to a man no
yeah they're discriminating they're
discriminating against the Post lifers
Yeah there yeah this is scary no this is
scary because like you think of all the
things that go wrong with your
technology all the time
like and also I'm sorry but who is worse
with technology than the really old
people which it's not on them like I I
don't right I don't even want to learn
any of the new stuff really okay but
like their Chip is going to be they're
going to be like signing up for all the
viruses yes they're always like oh my
chip got hacked and then you know now we
are getting nuked right like people like
put the people always say like the
finger on the button or whatever if it's
actually in their brain they're going to
leave themselves open to so much ha
they'll be like oh oh like my chip told
me I like I want a laptop you know and
then next it'll never be easier for
foreign governments to hack people
because they'll get the technology put
in and they'll just they'll trust the
interns to help them with it they'll
never learn any of it themselves and
then we'll all be screwed yeah and like
the like these old senators all be
trying to marry Nigerian
princesses Tyrus uh what do you do you
think this is uh um
realistic well if it's let's say it's
true can you start it
now because the we're hearing every
night I put a chip in his brain yeah put
so we can figure it out like I'm I'm
fine with that don't and if it's already
happening we we're seeing some of the
problems they need the updated version
yeah U we saw Mitch reboot in the middle
of a speech Yes you know uh Biden keeps
getting hacked by
Hunter so that's why you're hearing two
or four voices coming out of his mouth
at one time so uh yeah if they're if
they're going to do it do it now it's
just because everything they said is is
the side effect is already happening MH
so without the Boost we're already
dealing with they don't leave anyways
yeah and they're getting weird anyways
so if that me put a chip in their head
to make them go back to having to talk
and think they're smart that might be
better because then they'll be uncool MH
you know like if Mitch all of a sudden
got cool and showed up dressed with like
today's fashion like what it is is I'm
here to represent y'all they would be
like see cuz you can be old and scile
but you can't be old and cool no that's
true so yeah it might be a good thing
that they're all wearing like today's
stuff and like we're swifties yo we're
going to the see Taylor Swift and
everyone be like ew cool old people vote
them out maybe that's if they can put
chips in individual's brains and have
them lead us that means babies could get
this too um we could be led by babies
little infants that you know have these
uh precocious chips in their brain but I
I think that they put one in John fedman
and it turned him into a conservative
yeah it's
true he was red chipped yeah red chipped
exactly we just have to find the signal
and then we'll have remote control
Powers over our leaders you know be like
stage hypnosis flap your arms like a
bird you
know I would really look forward to that
all right well that was gloomy hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else